هي الخيمه اللي عايشين فيها 34 نفر بالضبط
اميات وابوات واولاد اول يوم نمنا على
الرمل هيك سلمونا كل خمس انفار بطانيه او
سبع انفار احنا حوالي خمس 34 نفر والله
تقريبا مش مستعدين للمطر مش مستعدين يعني
ه جيبنا النيل تو قدرنا ندبر حقه فقيت
وصلنا يعني مع كذا حد من القرايب لما
قدرنا ندبر حقه عشان نقدر نغسل الخيمه
نغطيه
يلا اول شي رحلنا على الشفاء بعدين من
الشفاء على هنا ومشي من غزه لحد هنا مشي
وغير الاطفال اللي معانا غير الحاجات اللي
عننا يعني
هدومنا حرماتنا كله كله راح في القصف
واللي راح بالشوارع اول امبارح نمنا هنا
امبارح نمنا هنا 15 نفر
هنات من 15 شردوا من الزج راحوا في الخيمه
هذ وشتت عليهم
اه
والله برد يعني لا يطاق برد بعد عنك انا
ايش بدي اقوللك ايش مكان ما فيش اصلا
ملابس طلعنا من البيت مش ملابس يعني خفيفه
ملابسنا وحالنا ومش قادرين نتحرك من البرد
ها خيمتنا هذه الخيمه تحتوي فيها بنام
فيها 40 نفر لغايه العتبه هذه الليله انا
نيمت بدمين هنا ماتوا سعه الليله ماتوا من
البرد الليله الشباب لا في غطا لا في نومه
زي الناس هيك شا هي رمل لولا الحصيره هذه
ناس ادونا اياها احنا طالعين من غزه
بطولنا حنقو هنا احنا مجرد اليوم نقطت
نتفه عمنا واغرقنا فما بالك الا ما تشتي
وتكبس الدنيا هذه الفتحه وهذه الفتحه يعني
مش مسكره منيح على قد ما قدرتنا
سكرنا فلما ما ترت ما ما تدفينا ولا شي
عملنا
نافي بت والله غير نطير معها غير نغرق
غارقه الذين امنوا مطر مطر يعني ذوبها
رشرش اغرقنا قف لما تنزل مطر كثيره حصير
في الشوارع ننق والحمد لله الله حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل
خلصك واهلنا مش عارفين وين راحوا اولادنا
مش عارفين وين راحوا بناتنا مش عارفين وين
راح نختار مكان عشان المطر ما تنزل علينا
نحط جراد عشان ما تمش المكان الميه وكنا
يعني كثير ليله سيئه بالنسبه
امبارح مطر وقصر وناس بتموت وناس بتعيش
ونيله على الفاضي يعني
الحياهه مش عارفه اشرحلك
اياها